this is a production of Cornell
University
[Applause]
well thank you Cathy there was a most
wonderful introduction
I feel kind of embarrassed I didn't I
think I have done those things that you
mentioned so I am asking as Kathy's
Kathy said I am an expert on taxonomy
insist I'm a system arrest and I work on
naming and describing and deciding the
names of organisms and also
understanding their phylogeny so that's
what I've been doing since the start of
my career with mr. Cerf and of course I
have moved and evolved in the field as
it has evolved itself I'm terribly
excited to be back at Cornell and I know
some of the faces here were my
professors or my colleagues then and
it's absolutely wonderful to be back at
the herbarium
where there's so much to do just
entering that herbarium is entering into
one of the most precious places in the
world because of other wonderful wealth
of fungi that are there not only from
the region but also in that disk of my
seeds so my my work has I work with
mainly with fungal diversity of tropical
fungi and I will not say only these
kamae seeds because some my students
back in Venezuela were interested in
other groups that were not discs my seed
so I had two broad and brought my
interest and work with other groups as
well I also work with ecology life
history and fungal communities I try to
understand the biology of this fungi
what are they doing why are they in that
environment
and in for this talk I want to wrap up a
bit and and place myself where I come
from in my lineage
of Cornell mycologist because as I stand
as they say in the soldier of giants and
it's true I totally do and most of them
in my cases the in Cornell mycologists
and I will one of the goals of this talk
is also to excite you and to make you
very interested in this in Co P
herbarium and in that Cornell herbarium
so that we you will deposit your
specimens there and you'll understand
after this stop why is that so important
so just to start with fungal diversity
this is a slide you must all know very
well there's all this saying about how
many funds are they are there 1.5
failure are there five million fungi
every time somebody goes and samples
does environmental sampling all of a
sudden from one centimeter of soil there
comes 100,000 sequences so nobody really
knows but if there are that amount of
fungi which probably there are we know
very little about them we know less than
5% probably of what's out there and we
understand even with as time goes by we
understand less and less about these
organisms because now it's all about
sequencing and if people have forgotten
how to describe or how to even look at
their organisms in the field less
understand their biology so I try that's
what I do I I try to understand the
whole picture that colette i go out to
the field i collect this fungi these are
all cup fungi as you can see there's
some of them maybe you will recognize as
for example this is a beautiful entre
cobia which we will be talking about and
this is herpes Isis and this is Vice
perilla some of this fungi or percolate
and some are in a particulate and I work
on both groups
so the first group I'll mention is the
group of or percolate fungi that precise
on my seeds and this is a real picture
it's not fake can you imagine a frog
just I see there and the person being
there at the time where that happened I
always dreamed it would happen to me but
it didn't this is a this is a photo that
somebody sent to me from Borneo it's a
collaborator that's working with a group
of us in a beautiful genus that I
mentioned I will mention in a little
while that's called cooky aina the name
over here so this comes from Borneo as I
mentioned this will percolate this kamae
seeds have the characteristics that
they're asked us opens by a lid it just
pops up and pops open and they're in the
spores are dispersed in that way that
that lid can be on the top or can be a
little err on the side the best majority
of this fandom the vast diversity the
highest diversity is in temperate
regions but in the tropics particularly
and or in the project throughout the
world the genus cookie ina which is of
the group that has a lateral lid is very
very abundant so for years and still up
to date we have been studying the genus
cookie ina with a group of people and it
since 2002 we thought it was way before
2002 with other word only for species
which were all that have been described
so there was a very hairy one that we
called one name a little one I was less
hairy like this one the kooky ina
speciosa group which we noticed had a
lot of difference in colors but when we
went to the microscope it looked the
same so we called it cocaine speciosa
and then a third one which was a little
smaller and then another one which I'll
show you the pictures there were four
species in the world we almost didn't
care to look very much Adam or for other
microscopy because we thought they were
those four and that's it throughout the
world in 2006 we started
working with colleagues from the follow
herbarium at Harvard Don Feaster and we
started working with molecular on these
groups of fungi and I was in Venezuela
then looking at all these different
color variations on this copy ina
speciosa and we started noticing things
so we started understanding a bit more
and going back to the morphology so
since 2006 only three species have been
described and it's not because we are
sloppy it's just because we still do not
understand what's going on with that
group it's so it's so this is just a
kooky Ines physios a complex and I'll
sure it ranges from all all colors but
that's the only thing that we see colors
and geographical variation there's no
morphological and as we start the
morphology at under the microscope
there's nothing that at content that
tells us there's any differences but
when we have done sequences of these we
we can see that's the spacer that's up
here it has different clay and this
clades really relate with colors and
which I have not marked there but this
is for example it's a coral this ones
are the more yellow
yellowish this words are the the whitish
and the brown one so they there are some
differences so people at the beginning
when they started describing all those
names they had for each color and I'm
talking about even the 1700s and the
1800s they were right they they're all
these names which were gonna probably be
needed to go back to and rescue but we
have been going back to the cookie ina
looking them under the microscope and we
have been noticing a few good things
that we had not seen before we have been
noticing some difference in the hair
some difference instructors and some
differences also in the growth and who
knows how many other differences there
are in the in their physiology which we
have not
look at so trickle OMA is a very
homogeneous played throughout the world
and this is the clade were called Cana
is it ISA is which doesn't mean much to
you at this point I just want to show
you this is an edible fungus it's it's
edible it's not a big fungus it's a
about 2 inches high and 1 inch in
diameter or smaller but it's the
abundance that it and it and because of
its colors when you're in the Amazon for
example in low tropical forests it
occurs so abundantly that you can even
pick them up like if there were seeds or
flowers so they are edible and in Mexico
if they're even sold in the in the
market I didn't believe this the first
time that's in an Indian community in
Venezuela
somebody told me and I said oh no you're
no you must be wrong and they didn't
tell me anything else so I totally was
in disbelief until I heard of course a
BSA word and they actually I tried them
and they're pretty pretty they don't
taste like anything but they have but
they have protein so this is a beautiful
drawing by madame legal expert on the
disc of my seeds were the intricacy of
this para feces is shown and also the
striation of the spores which is an
important character this fungus is very
particular this is only this cookie Ines
fisty also complex so that you can see
the color variation again from white to
brown from all these incredible colors
so this this is pre Coloma you can see
that the longhairs
it's very easy to identify and the clade
is very homogeneous throughout the world
there's just a specimen from China which
has smooth course and it's very related
to it and the last clay that we have is
a cookie ina is it is a clade which it
comes together with the other species
that we know and this one occurs only in
Asia
there are some cautions when studying
this fungus if you ever go to the
tropics and there are several programs
where Cornell takes you dance to the
tropics so you'll be able if you're
there you'll be able to find one if
you're in the lowland tropics you will
find cocaine a tree Coloma and and call
and speci uh the two that I've shown
mostly but there's a third one called
kooky I know Venezuela which can also
that occurs in Highlands in cloud
forests and that and I watch up so you
may be able to have some times in your
life to look at these fungus under the
microscope and I want to make sure that
you remember that color is important
that geographical region is important
and also that in this particular family
there's a phenomenon which doesn't occur
in other groups which is that ASCO
sports matter but you're simultaneously
so in h epithelium in each fruit body
all the sports will be in the same state
of development all the acai will be in
the same state of development
professor curve always was very excited
with this fact because it doesn't occur
in other groups of founders so it's
probably something very interesting to
study evolutionary by some of you so but
this has led to problems in the
descriptions some people have described
new species based on immature spores
because that this is not something we
see in general when we look at an
opposite on a fruit body spores are in
all different stages of development and
about what do we know about the biology
will we know very little at a certain
point I was painting placing pink
colored pins in the under besides he
tripathi's I did this for years but this
was in the Amazon and then uh there was
a huge rainfall and everything got
washed
way so then I did it with another
species that occurred at my university
in Venezuela again the same thing
happened although this these things grow
on little twigs and little seeds so you
know you can imagine having a pin next
to it and trying to watch its
development throughout time it's not
very very easy so after maybe one month
they are they are resistant they they
are long long-lived nothing had happened
but we do know there's an an imperfect
state called mole er diem Isis that was
described and as you know now there's
one fungus one name so now of course
this is called this would be called the
--it sexual state of cocaina in this
case speciosa and they said one fungus
one name is a big decision that was that
happened in the in Melbourne in in the
code in the in a meeting there in
Melbourne already in 2014 so it's been
quite a few years that this new rule has
been there in the code of nomenclature I
meant to bring the canoe code to show it
to you but I have it in the office if
you'd like to look at it so this second
group of find out that I work with are
the Leo show my seeds and these are the
ena percolate disco my seeds so this in
order of this group they're supposed to
be a very homogenous kind of Spore
discharge which is what by a poor I am
poor India in the apex of the Oscars so
through that little tiny pore which you
which frequently stains blue under
reagents that have a iodine so this poor
supposed to have some starch in it it's
it has been used in taxonomy to divide
these two groups and it holds
phylogenetically they sit the highest
diversity of cup fungi are in this group
and it's much more diverse than the
lyosha might seem worldwide the thing
with this groups is that in general
they're very very tight
some of these are beautiful and have
been really used throughout history for
example flora Siberia which stains wood
Green has been used in in making
furniture and when one sees those
beautiful pieces of old furniture where
there's all these little flowers for
example made in wood they're what every
screen has been made from wood work that
mycelium of this fungus is included and
these are other
lyosha that you know and Vice perilla
and one of the hollow siphay see so one
of the fungi I've been working in the
last few years the last two years it was
published I think last year is this
fungus which is kind of bizarre I had it
on my post on FaceTime and somebody
asked me what's that horrendous fungus
that you have there on your on your on
your post but actually it's very
interesting and the interest of this
fungi is that I look at it for a lot of
years and I I just started looking at it
and then I left it there I was
continuing with other things and then I
came back to it and there was something
wrong and it's placement has does not
prove anything
we did a I TS sequence and LSU and also
transect elongation factor of the of
this industry and studied other genes as
well and it just comes somewhere there
in the in the Leo show my seeds so
there's no placement and why is there no
good placement for this fungus because
they're very few of these hundred that
have been that have been sequenced so
really every time that we work with on
of this your show my seeds we find that
it comes to something it doesn't give us
much information phylogeny doesn't
really give us much information because
in the case of Bulgaria Lapua there is
an
cause there it has brown ascospores and
it has weird parentheses and I could
tell you much more about this fungus but
I will not I will just tell you that the
way the ask us breaks is very
particularly very particular it doesn't
break through a pore it just breaks like
another totally different and unrelated
group of fungus which which is by the
total break of the rupture of the of the
spore wall so at the end we end up just
with two walls and the apex of a site
disintegrates and thats how spores are
released there's there is here you can
see and little by little this took years
to understand and many many months at
least of understanding how all this
process started and continued and how
the world broke until only the two walls
were there and it has not been described
here yet lots of people had looked at
mulberry Ella and this only happened
because I looked and looked and looked
for a long time under the microscope
even to the point where I thought why am
I looking so much until until I
understood what it happened and he was
published like a important thing because
this had not been recorded yet so it is
important to look another thing another
issue I've been very interested in since
my PhD work and that was in 1990 under
professor course have been the
connections between the sexual and
asexual States which before each of them
as I've already mentioned have their own
name so I studied this little fungus due
to the persistence of professor course
which because this fungus is a quarter
of a millimeter in diameter very
difficult to find in nature and it took
a lot a lot of going throughout the
world and a lot of time in the field in
order to find a few of the species so we
did a monograph under on this
and also looked at its Animorph as it's
a sexual form which was called an pseudo
spy rupees now it's called straw Samaria
this is a very uncommon fungus in the
sense that they're usually not Brown
limitations animals connected to your
show my seeds they're very few and also
there are other characters in this
fungus so in this sense I have been
working at that time how did we do the
connections you must wonder there was no
molecular involved so there was no way
to know we did cultures very carefully
cultures have the ASCO spores of the
sexual body and single ascospores and
waited is it almost a leak or a turret a
leak is there something there so after
months when we had totally forgotten
that the cultures were there all the
sudden all of a sudden professor Corps
was shouting it's growing it's growing
and there was the pseudo spy rope is
growing there so again connecting this
and a morphing tree until you morphs
there is this fungus called tricolor
Javan iike and last year I went to
Mozambique in a very very bad time of
the year for a collecting trip I had
been invited to and they says you know a
national park Gorongosa National Park
and we have one has to collect with and
with a guard because of the elephants
and other animals so nobody's permitted
but to be under Jeep so it's very
exciting because you see an elephant
over there and you think there's a tiger
gonna come to attack you but nothing of
that happened we were scraping the floor
scrapings of everything because there
were so few fungi we were we were really
depressed and why did we come at this
time of the year until we started
finding things that were totally unusual
that we started finding these hairy
thing we didn't know at all what it was
I send it to some colleagues experts in
in animals nobody knew what it was so we
grew it in cultural group beautifully
lots of hairs coming from those petri
dishes and we were able to sequence it
and it's sequence
one of the few times it happens
identical with a hundred percent
similarity to trickle arena germanica
which was only known by its fruit body
and just a few years before there had
been somebody working on the on the
sexual state and had been able to obtain
the fungus in Indian culture the animal
fin culture but had never seen it in
nature neither knew anything about where
it occurs so that's pretty exciting when
that things happen so this is I've been
I am NOT going to mention other examples
and there are many of this animal TV
Merkle connection which now we are lucky
to be able to do using molecular if if
there has even been bullet molecular
molecular its DNA has been studied this
usually the case is not that usually it
lasts to nothing so then we describe it
as again the old method so the the third
thing I've been working with our fungal
communities and also last year there was
a big fire in the Smoky Mountains and it
was a fire that started in 2016 we
started studying it in 2017 it started
in November and it was it was contained
by mid December people died structures
were lost it was really the town of
Guttenberg was when we started going
there in March of 2017 it was very sad
of course you've all seen the recent
fires on the west coast and and that's
not unusual for the west coast but it is
unusual for the East Coast well it's a
sad sad to say that probably with
weather changes etc and I don't want to
use a word climate change but
it may be it may it may happen that we
get the abundance of water or more fires
also so when we started going there
visit what we saw there was nothing but
that's not true there was not there was
really when looking carefully at the
soil fungi in March were already growing
there and fungi specifically cap fungi
and some of the agarics were already
growing there so we went for once a
month during a whole year and we've
understood there was a fungal succession
present there many fungi repeated
themselves and some of his fungi we're
like where are they coming from all of a
sudden they were particularly - a fungal
community that's already known to occur
so it's some of these fungi already
known from the western United States and
all of a sudden did they come from the
west to the east
all of a sudden through the air are they
all around and then just land so I'm
gonna talk a little about the hypothesis
that exists about how are these
communities how do these communities
occur so some of the questions where
this disfranchised sorry are called
perilous fungi fungi that grow after
fire they're friends of fire and this is
geo Pyxis carbonaria on the top this is
more moral and I have some in my lab if
some of you want to see I'm not giving
out anyone because I'm gonna eat them
myself but I've been waiting for a
special occasion so I made make a dish
at some of the departmental parties and
we can all eat it so what is a fungal
community like post-fire and what
explains that distribution there's as I
said there was we found like 50 species
specific to burned sites and that's a
succession that was evident especially
on your number one i'm your number two
therefore there's forests growing again
and their other many other things
growing
but we did find new records and some of
them with totally unresolved taxonomy
still being work work that so this is a
group of ascomycetes that we found
specifically I am working right now with
an track obeah which is bringing again
some of the same things that happen in
cocaina are being repeated with entre
cobia Myrcella was the first report for
in the east this species of more
commercial exuberance and in the passage
of my kata there were new ecology things
that started up appearing in spring that
were known only from other seasons as
the same as my Cena and folio Highland
dances which was everywhere
wasn't a very much smaller form I do not
study agarics but there's a huge group
of colleagues from the University of
Tennessee working on this so these are
the most frequently the folio de geo
pixels Carbonari everywhere and this
fungi which are growing clusters and
they're difficult to get out of soil
because a whole clump of soil comes with
it so one can start understanding why
are there there this is the first report
of that wartella
which was already published and I have
mentioned and the interesting thing with
anta cobia is that they're also
different colors of hunter cobia
different morphologies in answer cobia
and undoing the 'enter cobia phylogeny
and on working on several genes of
hunter cobia this is only ideas we can
see that there are different clades and
here in a very rough manner just to
start with a one can see that probably
there's a species present but there are
other plates in between which we know
nothing about and this is probably not
on a track obeah in Ecuador but another
genus and there are other things
involved there which have been very
mixed up so at this point we're trying
to solve it and we have gone back to
trying to understand the morphology of
these groups and also we're finding lots
of cryptic species
there so there's a lot that we're
working on and we don't understand yet
only about these Geno's in particular so
I think you'll be interested in these
three hypotheses that I mentioned
already of what what explains the
distribution and I'll just mention them
very briefly the first one is the spore
dispersal hypothesis which says that the
spores come from elsewhere and finding
an environment totally with nothing with
no competition at all they start growing
but if this hypothesis has not been a
very if true genetic diversity should be
low in the population and spores to
germinate easily and none of these
things happen the second hypothesis says
there is for a sports corrosion or
sclerotium bank that doesn't get
eliminated when fire passes through I'm
sorry and and then they're dormant until
fire comes and they start growing and
the third hypothesis is the one that we
are working on some of my colleagues and
me which is called the Body Snatcher
hypothesis and it says that fungi are
present there in put inside plants so
this plants we have C sequence my
colleagues and myself we have been
working in sequenced sequencing masses
and sequencing lichens from the Smoky
Mountains and from other parts of the
world and the preliminary results prove
that that they are present in mosses and
that they said fungi are present in
mosses not only on the Smokies but
elsewhere so now there's an
environmental sequencing going on there
have been and I don't do not have the
results with me because they have not
been published and they're still being
worked by colleagues in the University
of Tennessee and Illinois and it's
really their work so but but they are
there and they're present though this
will probably be the most common
hypotheses the most real hypotheses that
they survive how do they first survive
well no but
sure yet but it can be related to the
amount of water that mussels have oh
that dry somes maybe fire sometimes
passes very quickly and the rhizomes are
there and who knows there may be a
combination of methods there may be also
some structures that persist on the soil
though it's that could be it's more
uncommon because here in the eastern
coast there that that particular region
had not had a fire in hundreds of years
for example so so that's a question for
you and the last part of my I'm
switching now completely to talk about
her barium and why do I talk about her
barium oh this beautiful fungi that
you've seen there and somewhere and
they're important to be there it's
important that they are that they end
somewhere and that they end as a
collection in a herbarium so this is
photographs that are taken from superior
barium which is a Cornell University
Plant Pathology herbarium that used to
be housed in this building in the third
floor and it's now it's in not too far
away some of you work have been there
and it's a it has a a wonderful space of
its own now in a game farm road so there
are all sorts of different kinds of
specimens starting by the password tool
which are just for for for classes or
for showing diseases etc to students
they are mounted in a way with cotton
etc that are very easy to pass around
and to show them and there you're
welcome to use them it doesn't have only
fungi have bacteria it has viruses it's
a it has all sorts of plant diseases
that they're very very nicely preserved
in this bus / - there are thousands of
password tools so the the most of the
collection started with Wetzel are in
they were they they are in this huge
boxes and
these are some of the atkinson's slides
so there are about 500,000 specimens in
the at COP herbarium find out from all
over the world and a new project were
COP herbarium has been involved since
May well I don't know 10 years ago it
has been the digitisation of herbaria
so the micro portal it's a project that
I was in both ways and see you Peter
barium has been involved with for many
years doing macro fungi and microphones
oh so now all of these specimens are are
digitized and 85 institutions from all
of the United States have participated
and from other parts of the world also
have participated CU p had an and kathy
had a kathy Hodge had a very good idea
in digitizing not the specimens
themselves but all the card catalog that
was there thanks to Wetzel and Korff and
so the whole herbarium was able to be
digitized in the sense that people all
over the world because this is of open
access can see what's there and can ask
for specimens that we have so we keep
getting requests for fungi that we have
and that people only learn off because
of the micro portal in the micro portal
they're almost 4 million records from
all of those institutions and I just did
a little sample that took me 15 minutes
because it's there are several tools in
the micro portal where I just said I
want to know what's the latin-american
fungal diversity and it just popped up
all these numbers of course this only is
including specimens are in herbaria and
the specimens that have been digitized
usually geo-referenced of course because
we know they're from Latin America so an
image sometimes so all of these
countries the number of records and the
number of species
besides that the micro portal can keep
can permit making heat maps so and
that's also done in minutes so it's
amazing when one tries this and what
other all the information that one can
retrieve from this portal and I did just
because of course I'm from Venezuela I
was interested in knowing that heat map
from Venezuela my own country so well
this is a little further down than
Venezuela but it includes because there
Nestle are usually should end here so
there's some must be some little problem
there within my capital I shouldn't tell
you that but it's true but here the
problem has been solved so this is
Venezuela and each of this that's
another kind of map that one can do in
seconds also where each dot represents
are collecting spot a just clicking on
the dot you'll find the species the
collector and the and the locality so
it's really a wonderful tool to use with
this tool one can learn also how fungi
are moving throughout the world if clay
is climate change affecting some
diseases and how some diseases are
moving from one place to the other when
they does DC start and where so there's
a lot of information that can be
retrieved from the literature and from
the micro portal so voucher specimens
are a vital source of information
nowadays we can of course the dude may
obtain DNA from specimens there are
hundreds of years old and new techniques
if that that did not happen when I was a
graduate student when I was sitting down
listen in this same room like you guys
some a few guys are there we we didn't
have those tools so in I won't say how
many years this has changed can you
imagine in 50 years
thirty years 100 years what information
will we be able to retrieve from those
samples so that's why we care for these
samples that's why it's important for
all of you to deposit your samples there
the organisms you're working with we
sometimes we get some organisms
deposited there but very seldom so
please do please count on the herbarium
there are many questions that can be
answered and you're welcome to come we
have great facility we have space we
have a dissecting scope so it's there
for you and we welcome anything that you
be interested for your research
oh this was supposed to be a before this
slide just but I I will talk about a
little just very quickly about a lineage
where I come from and as I said I stand
in the shoulder of giants and this is
the Cornell lineage you know all these
people which I was not named with their
students so Dudley Atkinson Wetzel
Fitzpatrick Korff and that's my name
over there we all come and we call each
other brothers uh so I call for example
Don Pfister my mycological brother and I
don't think I'm gonna have time to
talking in detail about some of these
people but Dudley was the first one and
I just want to say that there was like a
traditions like Dudley was the professor
of Atkinson and Duran and he has this
beautiful fungus named after him and
Cornell first president purchased
Cornell first herbarium in 1870 five
years after Cornell started why did they
was that important because having
collections was a pride of an
institution having collections and
having museums was as it still is
important so and people knew it so
Atkinson was as we know this wonderful
and incredible person who was a student
after what had to run fitzpatrick and
wets office students
what a wonderful photographer and
recorded and what did this great book on
mushrooms wet so how we how can we not
know wetter winter standing in the room
called after him he was the father of
Cornel Plant Pathology he started he
established the first department in
Plant Pathology in the United States
and the and the Plant Pathology
herbarium so he was as the professor of
Fitzpatrick under and in word with
Sclerotinia well he traveled extensively
throughout the world and had
collaborators but you can see over there
and I just want to mention to run
because we have in our herbarium that
around herbarium all this kamae seeds he
studied here but that wouldn't went
elsewhere but then he donated his
herbarium to see you P Fitzpatrick was
professor course professor and he was
responsible for the herbarium and also
taught a lot of my ecology courses which
then of course professor course which
died three years ago and many of you may
have known him he continued the work of
Fitzpatrick wonderful work in the
herbarium the herbarium grew throughout
the years with Wetzel and him until some
more or less four hundred thousand five
hundred thousand that it has today he
did an incredible amount of publications
as you can see there was a member of the
nomenclature committee for fungi and
when he retired I kind of I took his
place but I in that committee and he was
also a talented actor he was very good
in acting as can be seen here in his
photo and he was a student at Cornell
and this is not how he how he dressed to
come to class I don't think he was here
impersonating Elias freeze one of the
very important mycologists and he did
this and what asked was asked several
times to impersonate him in several
international congresses and he loved it
and he was he really was very good at it
this is a photograph Richard because
a president of the mycological Society
of America and this is a photo that
Cathy took of him on his 18th birthday
where there's professor Corp and there's
some of you there and I can see one
person over here which is Professor
professor nor peers standing at the door
so you see that tradition continues well
I've come now to to the acknowledgement
part and I want to I will not go through
the whole acknowledgements but I want
especially to thank Kathy Hodge
professor Hodge for inviting me to give
this talk for her many insights into
this talk and also for being a major the
major person that brought me back to
Cornell to be a curator at a plant
pathology herbarium I didn't I'm
delighted to be here and we have a lot
of projects that we are already starting
and we hope many of you will get excited
and also start working with us and I
want to thank all of these people that
are that you see there which have
collaborated in different projects
perfect donald Feaster from Harvard and
the Miller from the University of
Illinois besides all the other
colleagues Karen Hughes also from the
University of Tennessee they have all
been relevant people
Meredith blackwell from two on the in
this presentation in different ways so
thank you to all and I end with this
picture Venezuela or another two boys
which we cannot go at the moment but we
hope to be able to be able to go back in
a new need not so far future
[Applause]
logical significance colors well there
have been many hypotheses and the some
of them are dispersion there are logs
and there are different lots of insects
that that feed from the high minium of
this fungi so there may be there there
it may be a color may be there to
attract them also it's been said a lot
that their secondary metabolites and and
there are really toxins that accumulate
in in that the fungus doesn't have a
better way to get rid of and that's a
theory that I have read I myself have
not studied it but there are all these
sort of relationships they're also
mammals that feed from fungi and the
color may have some attraction towards
them but mostly we see worms and
arthropods a little insects are usually
feeding on them but you know I they're
not too many studies made on them and on
the Koki I know special so specifically
why are they growing just one next to
each other sometimes and having totally
different colors now we know that they
may be different species but what is the
color significance there you know you
can find white and brown and oranges and
all of them we thought it could be
related to light at some point but it's
not so we really and truly to answer
your question we have not much idea and
it may different of differ of course
with a group that we're talking about
your insights on the one fungus
nomenclature and I know a couple of the
agriculturally significant species there
have been some heated debates on what
the name will be are there some guiding
choosing what name yes and there is a
whole code that I have in the room next
door and I have all the codes of
nomenclature there's there these debates
are very very heated and very very long
as you're saying only to take the way
that one named the over one day one
fungus one name took 30 years so so you
can see there were there were all sorts
of debates in the Congress and the
panels and open panels and even boats
until finally it came to that there is
there still now so now at a certain
point it was decided that the sexual
stage would would be the prevailing
stage but not anymore
so tonight following Congress so lots of
people said why is the sexual stage
gonna be more important than the sexual
stage you know so let's go to let's
let's go by priority whichever name was
described was erected first that should
be the name but what about all the fungi
that pathologist know by one name or
that people in a medical mycology know
by a particular name or that have
economically importance of economical
importance so there have been committees
created to avoid this really terrible
fights they have in committees created
for each others of the different groups
and these subcommittees intensely debate
and decide together with with lots of
experts which name should prevail so
these are called now conserved names so
this lists are are of conserved names
just to make them different to some
central names which is another group of
names that were erected by freeze and
person and they have their own status so
but still but those those names have the
ability to be discussed so if somebody
and those are proposals so somebody is
not happy
with a name that all of a sudden the
organism has the person presents a
proposal and the basis it and then we
discuss it at the committee where I am
in and that takes forever and and we
vote one time and then we vote a second
time when we vote a third time and then
a year after we come for it and then
finally at the Congress now not the
botanic congresses but now a rule has
change also and we are able my colors
are able to change the rules in their
own Myka logic International mycological
congresses which are every three years
and of course then if they have to be
approved in the botany Congress so we
are still you know little by little
getting there if you want to ask me
about DNA type specimens no it's not yet
possible you cannot erect feel that was
debated a lot in the last Congress and
some of you were there and it didn't
pass so and there are a lot of I won't
get into that but I will be very happy
to talk to any of you about about why it
was not approved it will be eventually
approved but not yet many trees
sequencing has been done just how what
to what extent sequencing was done
thousands of well now now everybody
sequencing and we not only the
mycological community or the experts
also amateurs are sequencing all the
time so m so that's why we're having
more and more sequences and amateurs
have had a very important tool have been
a very very important group in in
in sequencing
because nowadays you can send a sample
somewhere and for $30 or sometimes less
you obtain a sequence so of course after
particular genes but amateurs have
become very good at this and in their
associations so that's why you see that
amount of sequence and we've been
already sequencing since 30 years ago so
some of these treats that you saw are
one gene some are five genes and and now
there's a tendency and a huge project to
sequence at leap try to sequence the
whole genomes which amazingly doesn't
cost that much you know in money value
it costs about three hundred dollars to
sequence a whole genome and so that's
that of course it's not little money for
any of us but it for a project for
example that makes sense so what you see
is true there's a whole lot of
sequencing that has been done but
there's so many fun joy there's still so
much more to do this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu